[Music]
so i wanted to
maybe awkwardly you can tell me after i
asked the question
bring back
what was once destiny is now a decision
and i may be putting this in the wrong
context but one thing that i feel i've
observed with my
audience over the last say year or two
in particular
is a certain degree of growing apathy
but i think the apathy is derived from
many different
factors one of which is just decision
fatigue and overwhelm
which is where i do think numeracy and
other basic
capabilities
come in very very handy so that you're
not just lost in the rapids of noise
but my question related to all of that
is
to what extent this is going to be
strange wording so
it's deliberate but it might seem odd
to what extent has
religion
been an advantage for you
in the sense
that it provides rules and maybe some
automaticity to certain aspects of life
i'm not religious but there are
definitely times when i envy those who
are
and i would just be curious to hear
any and all thoughts on that
can we talk about the first part first
about the decision fatigue
so i've been very lucky i
i got covered about a month ago for the
first time
it was really unpleasant i was in bed
for three days
couldn't have any i didn't have any
energy
and i was tired for another 10 days
beat just beat
but i had a lucky i didn't end up on a
ventilator i didn't die it's like it was
a bad flu
in the omicron phase here
but for two years especially the night
when i was in the united states before i
came here
i had a
i think for most of us it was a very
unusual life experience
it was a little bit not a lot but a
little bit like war
so war if you think back say the bombing
of of london
you think about it every night sirens go
off you go down underground in london or
you go to some place of shelter and you
come back out
if you're lucky your house is still
there if you're not lucky if your house
is gone and maybe somebody died who you
cared about
and can you imagine that night after
night after night and after a while
you'd say
you know it's really hard but the
hardest part of it is i don't know when
it's going to end
if you just tell me when it's going to
end
i can handle it just give me the arrival
date what's the eta
of the piece and of course most wars
they think oh it'll be over in a week
you know civil war it'll be over in a
week two weeks month
most wars drag on
as hard as cove it was and
again it's embarrassing to compare it to
or can you imagine what it was like to
to be in
london or berlin
or japan
not the united states because the united
states was pretty protected but in these
countries where
day in day out your loved ones were
dying
and you don't know when it's going to
end
and you more than anything else you just
want what do you want
just give me a normal day where i don't
have to be afraid not to hear worried
that someone's going to die so covet
gave us a tiny
thank god relatively much smaller taste
of that and for most people
i thought for me it was incredibly hard
it was like when am i gonna be able to
fill in the blank
right what am i going to have no i just
want a norm i want to go out to a bar
and see some friends and have a drink or
go to a party or better yet go to a
wedding or go even go to a funeral right
there are people who miss funerals who
miss weddings who missed wonderful life
events and couldn't participate
and so
i think
that really wore us down or a lot of us
down right it's very very
demoralizing there's some wonderful
things about it you faced your mortality
most of us i think had to recommend the
fact you know when i got my vaccine
finally it's like oh
now i i felt like superman
oh i forgot i'm still gonna die that
stinks doesn't it right but it forced
you to remember that that you're going
to die
you might die soon from covet
in a hospital on a ventilator or
horrible way to go
and if you're lucky you don't get it but
you're still gonna die and i think for a
lot of those two things when's it gonna
end and i am mortal and i most of us
again coming back to our theme
of things you don't want to think about
are easy not to think about the fact
that we're gonna die is
not pleasant must just push that one off
so i thought that those two things
really wore us down
so what does that have to do with
religion
i think
religion's really interesting obviously
it's a it's a
fascinating part of of human experience
both glorious and inglorious
i think people who aren't religious
think it makes life easy in the way that
you suggested the automaticity yeah
things are taken care of and there is a
piece of that by the way
i keep the jewish sabbath so if you say
to me i've got tickets to see
paul mccartney who i don't particularly
like but he's i'd like to go see him not
my favorite musician but he's at the
meadowlands with bruce springsteen is
going to show up which happened recently
i don't i don't know if it's a friday
night or not but if you said you want to
go i'd say oh yeah i want to go oh it's
friday night oh i can't go
so
for me
a lot of it does rule out
certain decisions that
that would otherwise you'd have to wait
there's no doubt about that
but i think a lot of people think that a
religious life is one that's free of
doubt and is a bunch of angels sitting
around singing
strumming guitars you know
a bunch of good martin guitars singing
some
kumbayas aren't uh it's really not the
main thing about religion that's
attractive to me and maybe to other
people
because i have plenty of doubts by the
way and i think most most religious
people in the modern era
struggle with faith i think it's a
i know i shouldn't say most many do
for me it comes back to what we talked
about earlier i didn't write about this
in the book but
it gives life a certain texture
and part of what i'm trying to say in
that book in wild problems
is that there's more to life than
the emotional ups and downs and what we
call fun or happiness
and there's a certain texture to life
that comes safe from being married or
being apparent or moving to israel or
having a certain career maybe in a
profession that makes you feel
full
and and yourself
and that texture
is to me a lot of what religious life is
about
it's the
again not that different from many of
the things we've been talking about
there are friday nights where i wish i
could do something i choose not to do
more globally
but the overall impact
has a
effect on how i see myself
and how i go through the world
that i find
meaningful
i don't think it's accessible to
everyone for me in my experience a
little bit like music
some people are tone deaf
and they cannot enjoy music the way
a great musician can or even a mediocre
musician
and other people have a great ear
and
all that music makes their hearts sing
all the time
and they live in a different world than
the rest of us and i think there's a
whole continuum of both music and
religious
slash spiritual
practice
that
we inhabit
that is personal that is person specific
it's like i give you my favorite novel
and you're gonna love this
and it didn't speak to me
that's what happens and there's certain
religious experiences or spiritual
experiences spiritual practices that
don't speak to certain people because
they're just not hardwired that way i
think i don't know
you